time for something of a toy story now as
McFarlane Toys has announced that
titanfall 2 will release this year
alongside the toy companies line of
action figures based on the first person
shooter I'm Lucy and welcome to this
collectible gamespot news update so Todd
McFarlane's toy company announced via a
press release that the toys and
titanfall 2 would launch in winter 2016
according to a promotional image on the
McFarland site the figures come in at
around seven inches tall McFarlane says
that titanfall and his toy company are a
perfect fit McFarlane Toys was created
so i could make cool stuff just like
this without saying too much about the
new game you are not gonna believe where
we can take this this release window
lines up with the previous report that
said that titanfall 2 would come out
sometime in es fiscal 2017 year which of
course lasts from the first of april
2016 to march 31st 2017 and while
McFarlane is keen to talk about the game
ea's response to our request for comment
was a little more coy answering with the
following statements mcfarlane toys will
be releasing toys inspired by titanfall
in winter of 2016 we have yet to provide
a release date for the next titanfall
experience from respawn so what do you
reckon do you think titanfall 2 is gonna
make it out this year let me know in the
comments box below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for the
latest on titanfall to keep it gamespot
you